commercial real estate down residential
real estate
up when you buy a home and it needs a
renovation the only two things you
should care about
kitchens bathrooms but a little ratty
movie theater that's not going to get
any capital spent on it and your feet
are going to stick on the carpet who
wants to go there
they're going to zero
see how nimble i am like a giselle but i
want to talk about
real estate and what better place to do
it than in miami real estate's
booming here it's exploding we're going
to check it out we're going to cruise
around
look at some of these amazing towers and
talk about prices
[Music]
there's some really crazy stuff
happening in real estate because i've
been a real estate investor for
20 30 years usually was the core holding
in my portfolio but that's
changed quite a bit so let me tell you
what i'm thinking
commercial real estate is going through
dramatic change why the pandemic changed
behaviors of
everybody all across america let's just
take for example
big office towers in new york city or in
boston
or detroit or any city you know before
the pandemic everybody went to hq to go
to work
everybody said okay let's get in the
elevator with 60 people go up to 78th
floor
but that's all changed we've proven in
this economy because of covet
that many people let's say in accounting
compliance logistics
they don't want to work in their cubicle
anymore they want to work at home
and they've learned over the last year
they can do it successfully so they
don't want to come back
so that reduces the demand for office
square footage
dramatically think about this you know i
know we're getting vaccinated and that
is great
but there's new strains every year
there'll be a percentage of the
population that never takes the vaccine
so covets coming back like a flu each
year
and i think people are going to be more
health conscious they're not going to
want to be jammed into elevators going
up the 78th floor anymore
they're going to want to work from home
that's a bit of a trend we don't know
yet the
total impact of it so you've got this
diminishment of the value of
you know office space and commercial
real estate and
retail space has a lot of stores and
third grade malls like really
cheap places they're not making any
money because people are buying
everything from amazon and direct
from com from companies that's called
the great american digital pivot
so there's another asset class in real
estate
basically 1200 square foot strip mall
stores all kinds of other malls
not doing so well that's the bad news
here's the good news people want to live
at home
they want to have their own space they
want to have a place they can live and
work raise their kids
take care of their parents whatever
they're going to do so you've got this
this two different spheres
of value commercial real estate down
residential real estate up
how up big time up crazy
up look at this city i'm in right now
taking you on a tour of
miami this is one of the hottest real
estate markets
in the world now before i go on i want
to talk about our sponsor this week one
of my favorite companies
you guys know i don't endorse anything
that i don't use
myself ever i'm wearing a robach
shirt i love this company i think they
sent me some shirts a couple of years
ago i started wearing them i fell in
love with them because
they stretch in every direction check
this out i mean this one has long
sleeves i love this thing it stretches
it every way
i throw it in the washing machine i dry
it i don't put it in dryer i know you
can but i don't
and it comes back you don't have to iron
it now i'm i remember my college days i
hate ironing stuff
look how spectacular i look within this
shirt you use the code
wonderful and rollback.com that's where
you go with it
will give you a generous 15 off your
first purchase
throughout the end of the week i love
these shirts i wear them
every day and i look spectacular
nespa they come shipped to you
they're beautiful i've got a ton of
these and it looks terrific
all right back to what i was talking
about so if you really think about it
you've got this split market you've got
commercial real estate
which i think is going to go down in
value over the next couple of years not
much but it's going to and i've taken my
money out of that
and i've gone into residential
residential real estate
is going to be really interesting for
the next few years think about it people
don't have to work in a ratty little
cubicle they'd rather have gotten the
burbs and worked there
makes total sense right but it's also
going to reflect in the value
of residential so you know if you're an
entrepreneur
there's no question the trend to
continue to buy homes
upgrade them they call it flipping i
don't call it flipping i call it
investing because you're going to fix up
the kitchen and the bathrooms
so let me tell you about investing in
residential when you buy a home and it
needs a renovation
the only two things you should care
about
kitchens bathrooms building
a movie theater in the basement total
waste of money
you don't get any return on that i know
it sounds cool to have a man cave
but the major purchase decision is often
made by the matriarch of the family the
woman is walking and saying where do i
live
in the kitchen where do i live i want
great washrooms
and i agree with that completely i love
to hang in the kitchen why that's where
my family is
we're always hanging around we're
talking we're putting the popcorn on
we're grilling outside coming
into the kitchen we sit around the
counter that's the zone that's the
family zone
every dollar goes there first every guy
likes to shave
in a nice bathroom i like a little tv
there
i like to watch little tv in the morning
when i'm shaving i like a shower i like
a steam
shower these are all great investments i
know everybody says to me put in a
bathtub i never use a bathtub
in the shower i love that that's the way
i look at it
so i would say that if you're thinking
about investing in real estate
go residential not commercial there will
be a chance
think about something like a bed bath
and beyond they close
200 stores across america
why because their online direct consumer
business was up 76
what's going to happen the stores
they're not going to be stores anymore
they have to be converted to climate
control pick packing
you know facilities with robots and ship
stuff out to the suburbs
think about those crappy little movie
theaters in those malls the tiny ones
not the big ones i think they come back
you know the imax that kind of thing but
a little ratty movie theater that's not
going to get any capital spends on it
and your feet are going to stick on the
carpet who wants to go there they're
going to zero
another class of real estate big problem
and i just think you have to be
pragmatic think about the way you're
going to live
even after we all get vaccinated which
by the way is not going to happen 100
percent
there's me a lot of people that don't
want to take the vaccine
so maybe 80 get vaccinated the other 20
keep bringing it back every fall that's
going to be a huge problem
i i just i want to talk about this in
the context of investing
because real estate is a core holding
for so many people and families
it's your number one asset and in
america owning a home has always been
what everybody wants
wow that was like one of those cigarette
suppose you could die at 100 miles an
hour
that's what you get in miami crazy
people i think they should stop that guy
he was speeding what are you going to
say
anyways at the end of the day i think my
thoughts are out there
no no net on commercial real estate you
wait 24 months
let the prices come down maybe go back
in then because i think they are coming
down
residential yeah everywhere
and if you're into it buy places that
need a renovation
and fix the kitchens and the bathrooms
and resell them
i think you can get really high returns
on that if you like that video
wait did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe i don't think these
commercial properties are going to do
well at all in fact i think they're
going to lose
a substantial portion of their value
over the next six months to a year